[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's a Prof hi Walter hi Martin how
are you doing okay uh more or less the
same as last time yeah yeah well at
least is it our weather has improved so
it was
freezing was the coldest day of the year
here towards the middle of summer yes
that's correct it broke a few records
mhm but let's not get carried away with
that because no it was definitely a case
of global
cooling uh we continue with most
important messages to the world and like
before we'll have to open with a word of
prayer because it's important it's a
very important message message yes and
we need help our heavenly father we need
your help every day every hour we ask
now that you Enlighten our minds with
the Holy
Spirit surround us with your Holy Angels
and guide this discussion and help us to
bring it forth to the viewers in Jesus
name amen
amen L and this is the final message of
warning to humanity yeah it is very very
serious
and we need to understand what it's what
it's all
about and so let's go through it
carefully and see what all the
components are you know many perceive it
as a very negative
message but in actual fact it's a call
to accept a very positive message it was
running through my mind exactly the same
thing people see this is oh it's a
judgment it's a bad it's you shiver when
you hear this message it's not supposed
to be like that it's not supposed to it
depends on your attitude yes all right
let's have a look at it okay Revelation
14:9 and the third Angel followed them
saying with a loud voice if any man
worship the Beast and His Image and
receive his Mark in his forehead or in
his hand the same shall drink of the
wine of the wroth of God which is poured
out without mixture into the cup of his
indignation and he shall be tormented
with fire and brimstone in the presence
of the Holy Angels and in the presence
of the lamb and the smoke of their
torment ascendeth for up forever and
ever and they have no rest day or night
who worship the Beast and His Image and
whosoever receiveth the mark of his name
sounds ominous doesn't it yeah yeah and
come to think of it how many messages
out there in the Christian world is
surrounded on the ominous side of this
and they're dealing with it everybody
has an opinion on the mark of the
beast but everybody has forgotten what
the Beast was that's a problem or is or
is so therefore they've lost whose mark
it is all right let's have a look let's
break it down and the third Angel
followed them saying with a loud voice
if any man worship the Beast and His
Image Point number one it's an issue of
worship it's not an issue of banking no
it's not an issue of any uh secular
activity it's not something to do with
how computers operate no nor has it got
anything to do with barcodes no it's an
issue of
worship how how do you worship and
that's very important all right and
receive his Mark in his
forehead that's the King James version
rendition if you go to the new
translations they have the word on there
as soon as you put the word on it can be
anything can be a sticker can be a
tattoo it can be something physical that
you put
there and uh is that an issue of worship
no not if it's not strictly speaking but
if it is in your forehead then what does
that mean cognitive you're thinking
about it right so it affects your
mindset decision making well an
extraneous Factor like a bar code affect
your mindset it might yeah it might but
is is still an extraneous Factor so this
has to do with a mindset it has to do
with worship or in your hand that's how
your hand
operates so the mark of the beast has to
do with worship it has to do with a
mindset and it has to do with your
activity as a consequence of the mindset
yes right so that M your decision making
affects how you worship correct and the
same shall drink of the wine of the
wroth of God now wine as we saw in the
last one is
Doctrine and if you accept false
doctrines then there are
consequences and the consequence is the
wrath of God now the wrath of God is not
a vindictive God that is pouring out his
wroth no it is a consequence of a choice
that you have made that disqualifies you
for heaven now why does it disqualify
you for heaven from Heaven because God
is a tyrant no no because you'll bring
disharmony into heaven exactly you in
any case you won't be happy there
because the rules that you don't like
here you won't like there because it's
the same rules that we read in the Bible
correct and then he will be tormented
with fire and brimstone in the presence
of the Holy Angels and in the presence
of the lamb now the fire and brimstone
that God talks about he gives us an
example like Sodom and Gomorrah were
destroyed until they were burned to
ashes so it will be and they will not
rise again therefore the smoke of their
torment ascendeth forever and ever in
other words it is a finality yes the
consequences yes it's not the smoke that
is forever and ever the consequences of
the burning and the smoke will be
forever and ever correct as you just
mentioned Sodom and gomorah they're not
burning still corre but the consequences
of that is still yes and the Bible is
quite clear they will be as though they
never
were and also there will be ashes under
your feet there will be no Resurrection
from this
destruction and then there's this
interesting portion here and they have
no rest day or night who worship the
Beast and His Image and whosoever
receiveth the mark of his
name now we need to know who the Beast
is we need to know what the Mark is and
what is his name Got to Do With It Well
his name always stands for character
yeah and because he is also Babylon it
stands for Rebellion against God's word
so it has to do with worship it has to
do with your cognitive understanding
your thinking about these issues of
Salvation and it has to do with your
actions if you do not accept God's way
then unfortunately you disqualify
yourself and there will be a
destruction and you will not enter into
the
rest and the Beast doesn't have rest no
neither does the image of the Beast have
rest in other words they've lost
something that leads to
rest yes is that right so have to find
out what what are they lust that leads
to rest and what do you need to rest
from MH that's a very important
question so let's go a little bit deeper
and see if we can unravel all of this
Revelation chapter 14
verse2 here is the patience of the
Saints here are they that keep the
Commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus all right it's an issue of worship
it's how you think about it and how you
act that's it right and it must have
something to do with the Commandments of
godh because here's the patience of the
Saints here are they that keep the
Commandments of God it's part of the
third Angel's message and they have the
faith of Jesus yeah now modern
translations like to change that in
Jesus so then you just believe in Jesus
do you think that the devil knows that
Jesus exists is H yeah him and his and
his Fallen
Angels uh is it enough to have faith in
Jesus or does the bible ask you for more
a deeper experience a deeper experience
because if you just have the faith and
you don't act upon it you don't have any
fruits all right so what kind of Faith
do you need the same faith that Jesus
had ah so you need the faith of
Jesus did Jesus keep his father's
Commandments yes he kept his father's
Commandments he says that as well uh was
the action and the activity of Jesus
acceptable to the father yes yeah so in
other words if you have the faith of
Jesus then you must walk like Jesus you
must talk like Jesus you must act like
Jesus then you have the faith of Jesus
then you don't just believe that he did
all those things good you want to have
him help you do the same all right so if
you have the faith of Jesus then your
Works will follow you yeah that is an
outflow of so it's very important that
it actually says the faith of Jesus
that's what you need he is your example
no human being is your example you need
to emulate the faith of Jesus and I
Heard a Voice from Heaven saying unto me
write blessed are the dead which die in
the Lord from hence forth
yay says the spirit that they may rest
from their labors and their Works do
follow them actually we should have
highlighted their Works do follow them
as well yes because it's not be it's in
the right sequence yes so they rest from
their
labors there is the issue of rest so is
rest a very important component of the
Three Angels messages very much so all
right so we need to know what is rest
entail and their Works do follow them in
other words first you must have the
rest then you can have the
works The Works don't lead to the rest
the rest leads to the works is that
correct that's it right that's the
essence of the Three Angels messages now
we need to unpack it so let's just look
at this rest issue Martin Psalms 95
verse 10 40 years long was I grieved
with this generation and said it is a
people that do ER in their heart and
they have not known my
ways unto whom I swear in my wroth that
they should not enter into my rest that
whole generation didn't enter into
Canaan yeah the whole generation in the
de in the wilderness yes they didn't
enter into the
rest so what is this rest all about well
they didn't enter in because they did
not know his ways yeah is it important
to understand God's ways yes okay
Hebrews picks up on this picture so
whether we're speaking Old Testament or
whether we speak in New Testament God is
not a God that
changes so I swear in my wrath they
shall not enter into my
rest and to whom swear he that they
should not enter into to his rest but to
them that believed not they didn't know
his ways for we which have believe do
enter into rest as he said as I've have
sworn in my wroth if they shall enter
into my rest although the works were
finished from the foundation of the
world God had created everything he had
decided on the Plan of Salvation even
because the Plan of
Salvation was in
before there was even a fall yeah all
right from the foundations of the world
and he spoke in a certain place of the
seventh day in this wise and God did
rest on the seventh day from all his
works all right let's ask another
question is rest part of the third
Angel's message yes all right rest from
works right does that exclude Works no
because they follow that they have to
follow they have to follow uh does the
Sabbath have anything to do with rest
yes because it's symbol of completed
work yeah all right that is the work of
a physical creation it was physically
complete and then came a memorial to the
completed work which was the sabath
that's it to celebrate it all right now
the work of recreation recreating Fallen
Humanity
Martin does that also require rest
definitely now if the creation was
complete and the Plan of Salvation was
complete in the sense that it was
already decided from the foundations of
the earth will there be a seventh day to
commemorate a completed work work yes
now who
accomplishes the
Salvation Jesus does Jesus accomplishes
it for you now if he accomplished it for
you is it perfect yes is there anything
you can add to it no not at all you sure
how about some good works how about some
good deed will that uh help it along
that's what I just wanted to say nothing
you can't work towards this you have
to believe it and accept it and then
your Works will show that you walk in
that way because if it's contrary then
also actually you're showing that you're
not don't have the faith that you need
all right so if I gave you
nothing I gave you absolutely nothing
and I said from this nothing please
create the entire world in seven days or
in six days would you be able to do it
no no you would say sorry I can't do it
now the same applies to Recreation
that's it he completed the work and you
have to accept the completed work then
you can enter into rest that's it rest
from what from the from the completed
work from the labor that it took to
complete the work and who did the labor
the same that created the first right
God it so the creation Act and the
creation act require the same divine
power and there is nothing that I can
add to it once this world was created
Martin can I enjoy it yes were there
certain rules for me to continue
enjoying it yes once I have been
recreated and I can rest in the
completed work of recre cretion can I
enjoy it yes are there certain rules for
me in order to continue to enjoy it
exactly yes ah all right so let's have a
a look at it so this puts a new spin on
the ball
right now the third Angel's message we
read in the great controversy is the
most fearful threatening ever addressed
to mortal and it's contained in this
message this third third Angel's message
the most fearful threatening ever
addressed to
Mortal that must be a terrible sin which
calls down the wrath of God unmingled
with Mercy men are not to be left in
darkness concerning this important
matter the warning against this sin is
to be given to the world before the
visitation of God's judgments that all
may know why they are to be in inflicted
and have opportunity to escape them
prophecy declares that the first Angel
would make his announcement to Every
Nation Kindred tongue and people the
warning of the third Angel which forms a
part of the same three-fold message is
to be no less widespread so it's a
universal
message it is represented in the
prophecy as proclaimed with a loud voice
by an Angel flying in the midst of
heaven and it will command the attention
of the world so it's a very serious
issue you see the thing is once again
you cannot have a lame message you
cannot only give the two angels messages
because it's not must give the third as
well now we know from scripture that the
second beast of Revelation chapter 13 is
the one that enforces the mark of the
beast
right now the second beast is an image
of the first beast in other words it
looks like him in character and acts
like
him so the first Beast we need to know
who that is we've defined it many times
we'll put in a slide to redefine it for
the sake of
completeness but let's just read what
the second beast does the SE second
political religious
power yeah it must be secular religious
because the first Beast
Catholicism as a system not as the
people within it the first Beast is a
religio political system and the image
will act like the first one did in other
words be prescriptive in terms of its
doctrines correct and it will be
Christian and it has to do with worship
Revelation
13:16 and he this is now the second
piece causes all both small and great
rich and poor free and born to receive a
mark in their right hand or in their
forehead and that no man might buy or
sell save he that had the Mark or the
name of the Beast or the number of his
name so here's a picture Martin of the
Vatican and the capit
and we can see that
architecturally they are an image of
each other yeah so the one system is the
same as the other system interesting
both are actually temples yeah because
they have altars in
them so the second beast which is
protestantism because we saw that
protestantism had become part of Babylon
it had fallen in the second Angel's
message this this is the one that will
enact
legislation that is to give honor to the
first
Beast so let's go to the first Beast
historically and we read about it this
is John Wesley's explanatory notes and
he writes on Revelation
13 and I stood upon the sand of the sea
and saw a beast rise up out of the sea
having seven heads and 10 horns and upon
his horn 10 crowns and upon his heads
the name of
blasphemy as we've said before this is a
conglomerate Beast of all the beasts of
Daniel chapter 7 a wild beast coming up
he comes up twice first from the sea
then from the abbis he comes from the
sea before the seven vials the great
hore comes up after them oh reader this
is the subject wherein we also are
deeply concerned and which must be
treated not as a point of curiosity but
as a solemn warning from God now when he
talks about the great that comes
up is referring to Revelation chapter 17
because she rides the Beast and on her
for it was written mystery mystery
Babylon the mother of harlots right the
danger is near be armed both against
force and fraud even with a whole armor
of God out of the sea that is Europe in
other words the nations of
Europe This Beast e the Rish papacy as
it came to a point 600 years since
stands now and will for some time longer
to this and no other power on Earth
agrees the whole text and every part of
it in every Point as we may see with the
utmost evidence from the proposition
following and then gives a Bible expose
yeah and it is basically a study showing
that no other power fits all the
criteria so this is what the reformers
believe the first Beast is Catholicism
and it is its Mark that is going to be
enforced by protestantism Under the
direction of the
political religious union church and
state of protestant America yeah now
let's just look and see whether there's
a possibility of this actually happening
right so let's go to modern history and
we'll look at an article in ABC news
from October 27
2023 what role speaker Mike Johnson's
religious views play in his
politics but his new role as speaker and
being second in line in presidential
succession has cast new light on how
those beliefs may color his positions on
high-profile culture War issues such as
abortion and gay rights Johnson a
supporter of former president Donald
Trump and a 2020 election Den they're
not very positive about him told a
Baptist newspaper who when he was
running for congress in
2016 I'm a committed Christian and my
faith informs everything I
do there's nothing wrong with that
Martin no and in an interview that Ed
Thursday night on Fox News Johnson told
host Sean Hannity that someone asked me
today in the media people are curious
what do Mike Johnson think about any
issue Under the Sun I said well go and
pick up a Bible off yourself and read it
that's my world view anything wrong with
that no don't you have this wouldn't you
have the same answer same answer I would
have the same answer as well so this is
very
encouraging let's go further some
Democrats have signaled that the
influence religion has on Johnson's
politics is
troubling this representative Jamie
Rasin said in a post on X that Johnson's
speakership is what the y looks like so
then now it's interesting because
theocracy has laws
correct Jesus said Render unto Caesar
what is due unto Caesar and unto God
what is due unto God don't mingle the
two and he never did don't we have to
have the faith of Jesus correct no
church and state no Johnson has
indicated that he does not believe in
the separation of church and state
spelled out in the first amendments
Establishment Clause Congress shall make
no law respecting an establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof now we've consistently
said that that will be overthrown yes or
it will
be placed in another light yes it will
be not come in and get rid of it it will
be redefined redefined that's it Martin
all right so let's just go a little bit
further and see how he addresses this
issue certainly there's a move to keep
religion out of politics and and to
rigidly enforce the so-called separation
of church and state the founders of this
country uh would have certainly
supported our efforts here today indeed
this common misunderstanding about the
separation concept is is important one
it's it's one that's it's uh useful for
us to address and I think today is a
good day to do it in fact it's one of my
favorite subjects it's it's a topics
that I've debated debated and and
written and taught university courses on
for the for about 25 years about a
quarter Century for two of those decades
I was in the courts uh defending
Religious Freedom cases and and I
learned during that time that I really
believe that this is among the most
misunderstood subjects in our entire
culture see most people today who insist
upon a rigid separation of church and
state St are unaware that that phrase
derives not from the Constitution itself
of course but from a personal letter
that Thomas Jefferson wrote to the
Danbury Baptist Association in 1802 but
the key and the essential Foundation of
a system of government like ours must be
a common commitment among the citizenry
to the principles of religion and
morality without these virtues
indispensably supported by religion and
morality Every Nation will ultimately
fail this is a great time to observe our
faith we should never back down so
Martin he says that it is
indispensable if you want to have a
moral society that the church and state
should be together on those issues right
that's it is it then possible to inact
laws that might seem biblical but in
actual fact contradict biblical values
that will be the um definitely possible
if we take for instance and I we've
mentioned it before when
Nebuchadnezzar came to realize that
Daniel's God was the true God then he
enacted laws it seemed right but it was
not because church and state are never
supposed to give laws correct here's
another statement letters and
manuscripts Volume 7 the so-called
Christian world is to be the theater of
great and decisive actions men in
Authority will enact laws controlling
the conscience after the example of the
papacy Babylon will make all nations
drink of the wine of the wroth of a
fornication Every Nation will be
involved this is a moral
issue is there a conflict of religions
at the moment yes it's raging isn't it
Wars about it is there a conflict of
moral issues or pertaining to moral
issues raging within Christianity yes or
people getting fed up with the status
quo yes especially the conservative side
they just can't take it anymore all
right so if the pendulum swings that way
and they decide to enact moral
legislation some of of of which might
actually be very good is it possible
that in the mix something will be thrown
in that negates God's Plan of Salvation
it's easy to happen Okay Jeremiah 18:15
says because my people have forgotten me
they have burnt incense to vanity and
they have caused them to stumble in
their ways from the ancient paths to
walk in paths in a way not cast up well
this is a very serious issue the people
have
forgotten yeah you know if you have
forgotten it means at some stage you
knew you knew and it means you might
have to remember all right so they
forgot the ancient paths and they're
walking in a path of their own
devising
protestantism were they shown the way
yes were they very clear the Protestants
on what the issues
were and is it possible that
protestantism for the sake of fraternity
M throws those ancient paths aside
definitely we've shown it also in the
Babylon is Fallen is Fallen all right
here's a quote from the great
controversy it is in this life that we
are to separate Sin from us through
faith in the atoning blood of Christ so
how are you saved Martin only by the
atoning blood of Christ and through your
faith in it faith in it okay our
precious savior invites us to join
ourselves to him to unite our weakness
to his strength our ignorance to his
wisdom our unworthiness to his merits
God's Providence is the school in which
we are to learn the meekness and
loneliness of Jesus we need the faith of
Jesus the Lord is ever setting before us
not the way we would choose which seems
easier and pleasanter to us but the true
aims of life it rests with us to
cooperate with the agencies which heaven
employs in the work of conforming our
characters to the Divine model has to do
with the way you think and the way you
act none can neglect or defer this work
but at the most fearful Peril of their
souls so number one The Plan of
Salvation
is linked to the atonement and the blood
of Christ it is a completed work that he
performed to save Fallen
Humanity Isaiah
53 therefore will I divide him a portion
with the great and he shall divide the
spoil with the strongs because he has
poured out his soul unto death and he
was numbered with the transgressors and
he be the sin of many and made
intercession for the
transgressors Martin more than 700
years before Christ this this prophecy
tells us what the work of the Messiah
would be what he would do he would bear
the sin of many and he would make
intercession for the
transgressor and the atonement would pay
the price for a broken law yeah Mark
15:28 and the scripture was fulfilled
which says and he was numbered with the
transgressors so the New Testament a
knowes that this quote refers to Jesus
Christ exactly and it also shows that
prophecy was fulfilled okay now the
talmud of course applies it to something
totally different and uh the New
Testament makes it very clear that we
are dealing with a prophecy concerning
Jesus Christ and that's the way it is
now the
atonement the Protestant view was God
the Father
exercises the Wrath by pouring it out
upon his
son and the son dies for you so then the
argument by many of the theologians was
so the father is the mean guy the son is
the one that you should Revere but the
father you should
hate but what if the father and the son
devised this plan together and said I
will bear the
penalty and the consequences of the
broken
law and that is death because the wages
of sin is
death and that is wroth because it led
to the death of the Son of God but it
was a joint
decision that they would absorb this
pain and this suffering within
themselves in order to pay the penalty
yeah to actually save correct now
Catholicism has a new view it say says
God the father has
self-sacrificing love and therefore
Jesus died but he didn't die for you his
blood wasn't spilled in order to satisfy
the
requirements of the broken law so in
other words it was a demonstration of
obedience unto death but it was
something that a saint could o do so I
could have done it so could I have died
for your sins Martin no but that's what
they teach that's what they teach and
that's why in the previous one we also
showed the the chest of merits Jesus's
death just filled the chest with merits
and anybody else that did similar Works
filled the chest even further right all
right so those are the two views so you
are not saved by the blood of the Lamb
the blood was
spilt because he was obedient unto death
but it wasn't spiled for you yeah
according to them all right let's just
make sure that we're interpreting this
correctly here is Alan Jones the
Reverend of Grace Cathedral in San
Francisco and he wrote a book
reimagining Christianity and in it he
States the church's fixation on the
death of Jesus as the universal saving
act must
end and the place of the cross must be
reimagined in Christian faith why
because of the cult of suffering and the
vindictive God behind it that is a total
Distortion of the Plan of Salvation and
the character of God and the character
of God of the atonement Jones also said
Jesus's sacrifice was to appease and
anry God penal substitution was the name
of this vile Doctrine so in other words
they totally negate the Protestant view
let's just go to the
scriptures Romans
325 whom God has set forth to be a
propitiation a Hilter on a mercy
seat through faith in his blood to
declare his righteousness for the
remission of sins that are passed
through the forbearance of God so Martin
are you saved through the by the blood
of the Lamb yes and it is his
righteousness that must be
appropriated not any righteousness that
comes out of my works right for the
remission of sins that are passed
through the forbearance of God to
declare I say at this time his
righteousness that he might be just and
the justifier of him which believeth in
Jesus this is justification by faith
that's it and it is a completed work
that was done at the cross and I have to
appropriated by faith that's it so where
is boasting then it is excluded by what
law of Works no but by the law of Faith
so there's nothing I can contribute I
can only rest in the completed work of
Christ right I cannot contribute to it
just as little as I could contribute to
the creation of the world
because man wasn't even there when it
was created except on the last portion
of the sixth day let's just make sure
Colossians 1:14 in whom we have
Redemption through his blood even the
Forgiveness of sins does that negate the
Catholic theology yes absolutely right
completely or verse 20 and having made
peace through the blood of his cross by
him to reconcile all things unto himself
by him I say whether they be things in
Earth or things in heaven yeah who who
did the work Jesus did all of it uhhuh
and through his blood I am saved and
it's also important to realize that this
blood that was shed for our sins was to
accomplish the victory over the second
death yes not first death no because he
is the Everlasting the Everlasting death
the only reason why the grave could not
hold him is because he had no sin and
the wages of sin is death but he said on
the cross my God my God why have you
forsaken me God has never forsaken
anyone in the first death no only in the
second death are you forsaken of God
Colossians 1:21 and you that were
sometime alienated and enemies in your
mind by Wicked Works yet now has he
reconciled in the body of his flesh
through death does the death and the
suffering and the blood of
Christ cleanse me from unrighteousness
if I appropriate it by faith yes
completely to present you holy and
unblamable and unreprovable in his sight
so only way you can be unblamable and
even holy is through faith in his
righteousness all right so do you have
any righteousness in yourself no no no
I'm I'm very glad lest you should boast
and Hebrews picks it up and says and
almost all things are by the law purs
with blood and without the shedding of
blood is no remission the Bible is not
in harmony with Catholic Doctrine so
Catholic Doctrine is based on tradition
and it's Pagan yeah it is Babylonian you
are saved by your works you do not
believe what God has said so let's have
a look at the Protestant position the
heidleberg
catechism how are Thou righteous before
God answer only by a true faith in Jesus
Christ so that though my conscience
accuse me that I have grossly
transgressed all the Commandments of God
and kept none of them and I'm still
inclined to all evil I have a evil
propensity
not withstanding god without any Merit
of mine but only of mere Grace grants
and imputes to me the perfect
satisfaction righteousness and Holiness
of Christ even so as if I never had had
nor committed any sin yay as if I had
fully accomplished all that obedience
which Christ has accomplished for me in
as much as I embrace such benefit with a
believing heart that is the reformed
position that is the biblical position
so in other words if you do not accept
this then you have no right to rest in
the completed works that's and you
cannot rest in the completed works
because you're still busy yeah trying to
save yourself
working
okay let's go to a quote from Acts of
the Apostles with great clearness and
power the apostle presented the doctrine
of justification by faith in Christ he
hoped that other churches also might be
helped by the instructions sent to the
Christians at Rome but how dimly could
he foresee the far-reaching influence of
his words through all the ages the great
truth of justification by faith has
stood as a mighty Beacon to guide
repentant sinners in the way of life it
was this light that scattered the the
darkness which enveloped Luther's mind
and revealed to him the power of the
blood of Christ to cleanse from sin the
same light has guided thousands of sin
burdened souls to the true source of
Pardon and peace for the epistle to the
Church of Rome every Christian has
reason to thank God the epistle to Rome
is a thorn in the flesh of Rome that's
true it's very interesting that it is to
Rome yeah I don't think it's con
coincidence here's another quote from
the SS of the times Luther searched the
scriptures with untiring interest and
Zeal and at last found therein the way
of life clearly revealed he learned that
it is not the pope but to Christ that
men are to look for pardon and
justification there is none other name
under Heaven given amongst men whereby
we must be saved Christ is the only
propitiation for sin he is the complete
and alls sufficient sacrifice for the
sins of the whole world securing the
pardon of all who believe in him as God
has appointed Jesus himself declares I
am the door by me if any man enter in he
shall be saved Luther sees that Christ
Jesus came into the world not to save
people in their sins but to save them
from their sins that the one only way
whereby The Sinner can be saved is by
repentance towards God because of the
transgression of his law and Faith
towards our Lord Jesus Christ both for
pardon of sin and for Grace to lead a
life of
obedience that's called sanctification
and you cannot do it on your own you can
have the belief in Christ but you still
need him to help you in your life of
obedience it is a work of Christ
performed
in and for
Humanity so what is the mark of the
beast contrasted to the seal or the mark
of God because there's a contrast this
word that we read there the Mark or the
seal it's the same concept so God has a
seal or a mark and the Beast Catholicism
has a seal or a mark Exodus
31:13 speak thou also unto the children
of is Israel saying verily my sabbaths
ye shall keep for it is a sign between
me and you throughout your Generations
that you may know that I am the Lord
that does sanctify you so where does
your sanctification come from from the
Lord who declares you
righteous okay and he declares you
righteous only on the behalf of the
righteousness of Christ all right so is
the Sabbath associated with this cannot
be it is a sign right yep so Martin if
you keep the
Sabbath then you are commemorating the
completed works of creation mhm
according to Deuteronomy you also
commemorating the completed work of
Salvation yes uh did God take the
Israelites out of Egypt or did they In
Their Own Strength go out of
Egypt that's why he didn't when Moses
thought it would be in their own
strength and that's why he had to send
him 40 years into to go and rewire him
uh very good point all right can you
separate the the Sabbath from the sign
of sanctification and salvation no no
Exodus 31:14 ye shall keep the Sabbath
therefore for it is Holy unto you
everyone that defileth it should surely
be put to death for whosoever does any
work therein that Soul shall be cut off
from among among the people so the
Sabbath signifies rest and it is the
antithesis of work exactly so now modern
people say if you keep the Sabbath you
have a Works based religion yes you're a
legalist you're a legalist but Martin if
the Sabbath signifies rest then how can
it signify Works in fact if it signifies
work you are going to die yes because
then you're not keeping the Sabbath
according to what it's
all right so the Sabbath is intricately
linked to this right this this is going
to get very
interesting and the robe of
righteousness Ezekiel
16:14 and thy Renown went forth amongst
the Heathen he's talking about his
church
Israel for thy Beauty for it was perfect
through my combless which I had put upon
thee says the Lord God but thou did
trust in thine own Beauty and play the
Harlot because of thy Renown and porest
out thy fornication on everyone that
passed by his it was all right so how
were you declared perfect through God
through his comeliness yes himself his
works his righteousness which who put
upon you himself he put it on you so how
are you saved through him and through
his righteousness
but they didn't like it yeah they wanted
their own Beauty to shine forth through
their works you cannot be saved by your
works you can only be saved by the
righteousness of Christ so Matthew picks
up this story when he relates how Jesus
tells about this Parable and when the
king came in to see the guests he saw
there a man which had not on a wedding
garment and and he said unto him friend
how comest thou in Heather not having a
wed wedding garment and he was
speechless then the king said to the
servants bind him hand and foot take him
away cast him into outer Darkness there
shall be weeping and nashing and teeth
what if you have the wrong garment on
can you be saved no
so if you don't if you're there in your
own
garment it's you're lost right you have
to have the righteousness of Christ is
it important to make the right choice
yes what's the consequence of the wrong
choice being thrown out cast outer
Darkness all right so this wedding
garment is the robe of righteousness
which Christ offers you which you must
appropriate by
faith here's a quote from selected
messages that's very interesting several
have written to me inquiring if the
message of justification by faith is the
third Angel's message and I have
answered it is the third Angel's message
in
ity in its fullness it is the message so
is it a negative message or a positive
message that's the main thing it's a
positive message but if you refuse to
accept it then the consequences are very
negative then unfortunately it does not
become a very positive message okay
there's another quote from
evangelism this message was to bring
more prominently before the world the
uplifted Savior the sacrifice for the
sins of the whole world it presented
justification through faith
inur that's the same as in
Verity it invites the people to receive
the righteousness of Christ which is
made
manifest in obedience to all the
Commandments of God Martin there's a
mouthful there's the isn't this in
harmony with the scripture and they rest
but their Works do follow them exactly
so the works are a consequence of
accepting the righteousness of Christ
you have to have the faith of Jesus did
he walk in harmony with God's
Commandments yes did he keep the Sabbath
he kept the Sabbath so must I do the
same you see the problem now is like you
mentioned
before if you want to say to somebody
that keeps a Sabbath today he's a
legalist why did Jesus Keep it not to be
a legalist no because it was an outflow
of his obedience to his father correct
so they needed to have their eyes
directed to his Divine
person his merits and his changeless
love for the Human family all power is
given into his hands that he may
dispense Rich gifts unto men imparting
the Priceless gift of his own
righteousness to the helpless human
agent this is the message that God
commanded to be given to the world it is
the third Angel's message which is to be
proclaimed with a loud voice and
attended with the outpouring of his
spirit in a large measure you cannot
divorce the righteousness of Christ from
the third Angel yeah it's the essence
it's the Verity it is the sity it is the
substance of the third Angel's message
but it has something to do with the way
you act because it's also dealing with
something on your hand yes all right
Martin so let's just make sure what the
central pillar of the Reformation was
remember that they forgot their ways
yeah correct they forgot their ways they
have to remember they were perfect when
they had his comeliness but then they
forgot yeah Martin Luther said uh the
doctrine of justification by faith alone
nothing can be yielded or surrendered
nor can anything be granted or permitted
contrary to the same it's the heart of
the
Gospel Martin Luther stated if the
article of justification is lost all
Christian doctrine is lost at the same
time this Doctrine justification is the
head and the Cornerstone it alone begets
nourishes builds preserves and defends
the Church of God and without it the
Church of God canot exist for one hour
when the article of justification has
fallen everything has fallen Babylon has
fallen Fallen Fallen it's interesting
that he repeats it here as well right
it's fascinating to me how it fits
together so Martin the next thing we
need to do is just to make absolutely
sure that Martin Luther's view is in
harmony with scripture yeah so let's go
to galatian
3:1 but that no man is justified by the
law in the sight of God is evident for
the just shall live by faith is that in
harmony with his view exactly the same
Romans 3:28 therefore we conclude that a
man is justified by faith without the
Deeds of the laws is that in harmony yes
yes but then let's not forget verse 31
do we then make void the law through
faith God forbid we establish the law
there is the Crux of the matter so the
law is not at fault I'm at fault that's
it and Christ died because of the broken
law if he could have changed the law he
need not have died exactly so if the law
stands then the cross is the guarantee
that the law stands but I'm not
justified by keeping the law because I'm
actually dead that's it a dead man
cannot keep the law so I need to be
justified
by Christ I need to have imputed and
imparted righteousness in order to have
life and the life which I live is the
life of the Son of God that lives in me
and then the outflow of that life will
be to keep the law yes we establish the
law The Works follow follow Revelation
12:17 and the dragon was wroth with the
woman and went to make war with the
remnant of her seed which keep the
Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ so do they
keep the Commandments yes is it works
based no it's consequence-based
faith-based and then the consequence is
an outflow of does God want to bring you
back into harmony with his will M then
you must keep the Commandments right
Romans 10:3 and they being ignorant of
God's righteousness and going about to
establish their own righteousness have
not submitted themselves unto the
righteousness of God
and being found in him not having my own
righteousness Philippians 3:9 which is
of the
law but that which is through the Faith
of Christ the righteousness which is of
god by faith it's very clear the
scripture tells you that this is the way
to Salvation anything other than that is
spous here has a quote from selections
from testimonies to managers and workers
oh only those who receive the Seal of
the Living God will have the passport
through the gates of the holy city but
there are many who take upon themselves
responsibilities in connection with the
work of God who are not wholehearted
Believers and while they remain thus
cannot receive the Seal of the Living
God they trust in their own
righteousness which the Lord accounts as
foolishness and presumption this is the
heart of the Gospel it cannot be comprom
promised in any way
whatsoever now Martin just recently the
world witnessed a joint signing on the
Declaration of justification yes the pro
by the Protestant by the Protestant
world to bring Catholicism and
protestantism back into harmony but the
two were mutually exclusive and
compromises impossible so let's look
what happened most of the Christian
world knows that something dramatic
happened in alburg Germany on October 31
1517 on that day an obscure monk named
Martin Luther ambled up to The North
Door of the castle Church in vitberg and
nailed 95 Theses to the door the sheer
idea of indulgences brings to Center
Stage the word forgiveness in reality
indulgences are the end result of a
complex theological Labyrinth all
centered around the word forgiveness
forgiveness in in turn is related to the
question of punishment hell and heaven
overall these things are related to the
mission of Jesus Christ and the gospel
of Salvation this comes from a Christian
witness to Roman Catholicism it's a
Protestant based
organization what many Christians may
not know is that on October 31st
482 years after Luther lodged his
process and another dramatic event took
place on the very site the same place
choosing the very same day and location
of Luther's challenge representatives of
the Roman Catholic religion and the
Lutheran World Federation signed an
agreement intitled joint Declaration on
the doctrine of
justification hailed by some enthusiasts
as an end to the Roman Catholic
Protestant divide this document has
received much press and attention
mention the world
over so let's get to the heart of the
joint Declaration on
justification we read this is their
confession together we confess by grace
alone in faith in Christ's saving work
and not because of Any Merit on our part
we are accepted by God and receive the
Holy Spirit who renews our heart while
equipping and calling us unto good works
and then they comment and they say
notice by grace alone is not the same as
by faith
alone notice not because of Any Merit on
our part does not exclude Merit produced
by the spirit of God notice receiving
the holy spirit is not defined Rome
believes that the holy spirit is called
down in the waters of infant baptism and
imprinted in confirmation Christians do
not there's actually a lot more to this
model
by grace
alone in faith in Christ saving
works is not the same as by faith alone
in his atoning blood correct it's it's
something totally different it's back to
the chest Merit chest yes I can be
graceful and I can offer you
Grace but I cannot offer you atonement I
can only offer you Grace
so this statement is a
goblook by grace alone should read by
faith alone in Christ's saving blood but
it reads in Christ's saving work that's
Catholic Doctrine yeah and then it says
and not because of Any Merit on our part
we are accepted by God and receive the
Holy Spirit who renews our hearts while
equipping and calling us to Good Works
that is not justification that is
sanctification so this is in the first
place not a statement on
justification and it is a rewrite to
seem to appease Protestants but it is
Catholic Doctrine in totality yeah it is
not a it is a compromise on the part of
protestant but it is a
sellout so what did T Palmer say
apparently full consent of Pope Francis
he said we Protestants who
signed this joint document are not
protesting the doctrine of salvation by
the Catholic church anymore we now
preach the same
gospel and he says the word is there but
it's Grace it's not Faith Martin this is
such a travesty of Justice
unbelievable what was Luther's view on
compromise the negotiation about
doctrinal agreement displeases me
altogether for this is utterly
impossible unless the pope has his
papacy
abolished therefore avoid and flee those
who seek the middle of the road think of
me after I am dead and such middle of
the road men arise for nothing good will
come of it there can be no
compromise this joint declaration is it
a
compromise 100% so
unfortunately they came back under
mother's protection all right I will go
further Martin it's not a
compromise because a compromise is
somebody gives away and the other one
gives away and then you meet meet a
compromise no this is a total sellout
that's it because Rome did not move no
Rome didn't move one iota just rephrased
it to fool Protestants and they fell for
it hook line and
sinker and so in
1999 we have the chrisan chran ker and
Edward Idris Cardinal Cassidy signed the
joint Declaration on
justification it was no joint
declaration it was a one-sided
copout it was a surrender surrender the
Methodist joined the Declaration on
justification and they signed the
document and then the Evangelical World
joined it the world communion of
reformed churches joined the Catholic
Lutheran agreement on justification so
they all signed it did protestantism
give up its Central Doctrine in the
process yes yes you see if they would
have understood the true meaning of the
attonement and its relation to the law
of God they would have not fallen into
this trap correct but because they'd
given up the law and said the law is no
longer
relevant they were easy targets to fall
into this trap so if we read in steps to
Christ one of the most wonderful books
that exist in the world today the whole
heart must be yielded to God or the
change can never be wrought in Us by
which we are to be restored to his
likeness by Nature we are alienated from
God the Holy Scripture describes our
condition in such words as these dead in
trespasses and sins the whole head is
sick the whole heart faint no soundness
in it we are held fast in the snare of
Satan taken captive by him at his will
and quotes Ephesians and Isaiah and
Timothy God desires to heal us to set us
free but since this requires an entire
transformation the renewing of our whole
nature we must yield ourselves holy to
him the Warfare against self is the
greatest battle that was ever fought the
yielding of self surrendering all to the
will of God requires a struggle but the
soul must submit to God before it can be
renewed in Holiness I cannot contribute
I can only submit submit and then let
God do the work in you correct well you
have this famous example in the Bible in
Luke chapter 18 two men went up to the
temple to pray the one a Pharisee the
other a Publican the he stood and prayed
thus with himself God I thank thee that
I am not as other men are extortioners
unjust adulterers or even as this
Publican I fast twice a week I give
tithes of all I possess and the Publican
standing a far off would not lift up so
much as his eyes unto heaven but smote
upon his breath saying God be merciful
to me a sinner I tell you this man went
down to his house Justified rather than
the other for everyone that exalts
himself shall be abased and he that
humbleth himself shall be
exalted it's not easy for Humanity
Humanity to Humble themselves it's a
very difficult thing and therefore they
they by natural tendency choose that
Path Martin you can only be saved
through the righteousness of Christ so
what does the Catholic Doctrine state
and remember it's infallible these are
ex cathedra statements from the bishop
SE it's unchangeable and cannot be
retracted no if anyone says that the
Justice received is not preserved and
also not increased before God through
good works but that those works are
merely the fruit and sign of
justification obtained but not the cause
of its increase let him be
anma that is a negation of the scripture
it's directly opposite it's the opposite
of the Protestant Doctrine and it is a
negation of scripture so the the problem
is you cannot even if doesn't matter
what happens you cannot sign a
declaration of joint uh agreement with
Rome with Rome because they cannot
change their position there's a further
statement that was made at Vatican 2 for
it is the Liturgy through which
especially in the Divine sacrifice of
the Eucharist all of that is a
blasphemy because there is no Divine
sacrifice of the Eucharist because by
one sacrifice he has forever made
perfect and the Liturgy is everything
that happens in a service the work of
our Redemption is accomplished where's
the blood there no way no way and it is
through the Liturgy especially that the
faithful are enable to express in their
lives and manifest to the others the
mystery of Christ and the real nature of
the true church Martin that totally
negates the atonement you see it's also
important to State these things to
realize because we are busy with the
third Angel and it's this is still
identifying the Beast and what it
teaches what it teaches yes and why if
you follow it you are worshiping the
Beast yeah and why if you follow it you
will be lost and you will take his Mark
yes there another magnificent quote from
the signs of the times all who have
determined to serve God will seek to
know and to do his will at whatever cost
to themselves the true servant of God
will be made manifest by their willing
obedience to all the Commandments of
their Master if you love me keep my
Commandments if you don't do it you're a
liar and the truth is not in you it's as
simple as that right they will not be
murmuring and finding fault with the law
but will declare by word and action this
is the love of God that we keep his
Commandments and his Commandments are
not great
Grievous in obeying the law they are
doing that which is well pleasing in the
sight of heaven and all the promises of
the word of God are pledged to the
support of the faithful and obedient
they may hope in his Mercy build in on
his immutable counsels obtain the
desires of their hearts because their
Wills are placed on the side of God's
will it is their meat to do the will of
God and to finish his work the gates of
the Eternal City shall be open for the
nation that has kept the truth the
Servants of God shall eat of the tree of
life and enjoy the unsearchable riches
of
Eternity the man said to Jesus what must
I do to inherit eternal life keep the
Commandments was the
answer now Martin here's another little
tidbit that has to come into the third
Angel's message and we'll have to look
at this from a Biblical perspective as
well this comes com from medical
Ministry page 188 the medical missionary
work is as the right hand and arm to the
third Angel's message which must be
proclaimed to a fallen world and
Physicians managers and workers in any
line in acting Faithfully their part are
doing the work of the message from them
the sound of the truth will go forth to
every nation and Kindred and tongue and
people in this work the Heavenly Angels
bear a part they awaken spiritual joy
and Melody in the hearts of those who
have been freed from suffering and joy
and Thanksgiving to God arise from many
hearts that have received the precious
truth soan medical missionary work
healing the body is part of the message
yes because out of that comes healing of
the mind okay the Lord Jesus is our
example he came to the world as a
servant of mankind he went from City to
City from Village to Village teaching
the Gospel of the kingdom and Healing
The Sick Christ spent more time in
healing than in
teaching so this is part of the message
we'll come back to this a little bit
later let's look at the Seal of
authority because you have to be sealed
right that's what we've read before and
if you are sealed that's your passport
to Heaven yeah but your passport to
Heaven is the robe of righteousness so
that's the seal so the seal and the and
the robe of righteousness must be in
harmony with each other
right so let's look at the Seal of
authority we find it in Exodus
20 in the heart of the
decalogue and it's about the Sabbath
commandment remember the Sabbath to keep
it holy six days shall you labor and do
all your work but the seventh is the
Sabbath of the Lord thy God in it Thou
shalt not do any work thou nor thy son
nor thy daughter thy man servant nor thy
mid servant nor thy cattle nor thy
stranger that is within thy Gates so you
must rest on the Sabbath day why for in
six days the Lord made Heaven and Earth
the sea and all that in them is and
rested the seventh day wherefore the
Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
hallowed it this commandment gives
authority to the entire decalogue true
why because it tells you who the law
Giver is it's the Lord the word there is
y
mhm it's the name of
God he made that is his title he's the
Creator yeah and this is his
jurisdiction Heaven and Earth his
territory like any seal of the president
of the United States must have those
components to enact the law you must say
I name whatever it
is then your title president and then
the territory the United States of
America or any other Nation the same
applies so the seal gives authority to
the law without the Sabbath commandment
the entire law could be by Jo blow
that's it anybody can anybody could do
it right and it also says remember and
we've clearly seen that everybody forgot
correct just just make sure Isaiah 58 if
to turn thy foot from the Sabbath from
doing the pleasure on my holy day and
call the Sabbath a delight the holy of
the Lord honorable and shall honor him
not doing thine own ways nor finding
thine own pleasure nor speaking thine
own words then shalt thou Delight
thyselves in the Lord and I will cause
thee to ride upon the high places of the
earth and feed thee with the heritage of
Jacob thy father for the mouth of the
Lord has spoken it the Sabbath is linked
to the heritage of Jacob which is
eternal life
also the sons of the stranger that join
themselves to the Lord to serve him to
love the name of the Lord to be his
servants everyone that keepeth the
Sabbath from polluting it so was it only
for the Jews Martin no for the whole
world and taketh hold of my Covenant
even them will I bring to my Holy
Mountain and make them joyful In My
House of Prayer so the Sabbath is for
all nations it's not a Jewish sabbath
it's for mankind correct and you must
call it a delight because you are
resting you're not working you are
resting in the completed work the Plan
of
Salvation so the prophet Isaiah points
out the ordinance which has been
forsaken th shall raise up the
foundations of many generations and thou
shalt be called the repairer of the
breach so this prophecy applies also to
our time the breach was made in the law
when the Sabbath was changed by the Rish
power but the time has Has Come For That
Divine institution to be restored the
breaches to be repaired and the
foundation of many generations to be
raised up so there's a breach in the law
yes and it has to do with rest that's it
therefore it has to do with the way in
which you are saved that justification
or not that's it and that breach was the
reason that all these other ones could
go and sign because they didn't there
was a breach in the law and they didn't
want to keep their whole law so now they
could compromise they can compromise
Deuteronomy 66 and these words which I
command you this day shall be in thine
heart talking about the law of
God Thou shalt teach them diligently
unto thy children shalt talk of them
when thou sest in thine house and when
thy wst by the way and when thou liest
down and when thou risest up and thou
shalt bind them for a sign upon thine
hand and they shall be as frontlets
between Thine Eyes where must the law of
God
be in your cognitive decision making and
you must act accordingly it's here and
then it's an outf flow to your do
correct now listen what it says here and
thou shalt bind them for a sign upon
thine hand and they shall be as
frontless between your eyes there's no
all there it's not I'll accept half yeah
I'm going to work my way and you got to
have accept them both you've got to
believe it and you got to do it yeah
here's another one Exodus 13:9 it shall
be a sign for thee upon thine hand and
for a memorial between thine eyes that
the Law's law may be in thy mouth for
with a strong hand has the Lord brought
thee out of Egypt it's talking about
Redemption
y so the law must be there on the hand
and on the
forehead the alternative is the mark of
of the Beast he's happy if it's one or
the other if you really believe it
that's great but if you just do what you
told that's also okay doesn't matter and
if you just believe it and don't do it
he's also okay with it now we've had
this slide before the character of God
and the character of the law that both
of them are just true pure light
faithful good spiritual holy truth life
righteousness perfect and forever so you
cannot separate the law from the
character of God
impossible Deuteronomy 28:9 the Lord
shall establish thee a holy people unto
himself as he has sworn unto thee if
Thou shalt keep the Commandments of the
Lord thy God and walk in his ways is it
a condition yes depart from me says
Psalms 190 ye evildoers for I will keep
the Commandments of
God now that's Old Testament Martin
hasn't that changed no the New Testament
is supposed to have taken this all away
all right let's read ma Matthew 19 ver1
17 and he said unto him why callest thou
me good there is none good but one that
is God but if they will enter into life
keep the Commandments you were just
mentioning earlier
about the Young Ruler coming to ask
isn't it interesting that when Jesus
when he asked Jesus said go and keep the
commandments so where did he take it
away he never took it away and the
dragon was wroth with a woman and went
to make war with the remnant of her seed
which keep the Commandments of God and
have the testimony of Jesus so is there
a conflict between those that keep the
law and those that don't yes 14 vers2
says the same as the patience of the
Saints here are they that keep the
Commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus in other words they do what he did
mhm and they is the law gone no of
course not and it's on two legs all
right now that's the biblical way let's
look at the presumption of Rome Daniel
7:25 and Daniel 7 speaks about the exact
same power as Revelation
13 and he the Antichrist power shall
speak great words against the most high
and shall wear out the Saints of the
most high and think to change times and
laws and they shall be given into his
hand until a time and times and the
dividing of times now we're not going to
go into the whole prophecy but the fact
of the matter is that this power will be
so presumptuous as to think that he can
change times and
laws which commandment deals
specifically with time the fourth
Commandment okay but the Judgment shall
sit and they shall take away his
Dominion to consume and to destroy it
unto the end so if you think that you
can change God's
laws then you will be destroyed yeah
okay so who changed the law
let's ask the papacy itself the pope has
power to change times to abrogate laws
and to spense with all things even the
precepts of Christ is that one of the
most arrogant statements you've ever
read in your life definitely and that
puts it without Beyond a doubt okay that
they qualify for what we previously read
of what the Antichrist will be Martin
how do I know that God is a god of
patience and Grace well we can see that
God is longsuffering by this still
carrying on for Millennia already all
right so Martin if God really was such a
tyrant lightning should have come down
from heaven
right here's another statement of course
the Catholic Church claims that the
change was her act and the ACT is a mark
of her ecclesiastical power and
authority in religious matters well they
can change the precepts of Christ so
it's a mark of their
power suay is our Mark of authority the
church is above the Bible and this
transference of Sabbath OBS servant is
proof of this that fact Martin these
statements are so
arrogant so Martin if they say Sunday is
their Mark of
authority then the Sabbath isn't that
the mark of God's authority Jesus said
it Jesus said that he is Lord of the
Sabbath all right so if you keep the
Sabbath whose authority are you
acknowledg in God's Authority okay and
if Jesus is the word then should you
base your your thinking on the authority
of the word or the authority of the Pope
the authority of the word of course so
solar scrip yeah okay they actually call
it their Mark and they are the Beast so
isn't it the mark of the beast not very
difficult it's not rocket science and
it's about worship not about banking
right and what did they say they they
can even change Jesus's precepts and
that's blasphemy all right here's
another quote from the Catholic converts
catechism the Pope's will stands for
reason he can dispense above law and of
wrong mate right by correcting and
changing laws he even said that he could
change Jesus's
laws which is the Sabbath day Saturday
is the Sabbath day why do we observe
Sunday instead of Saturday we observe
Sunday instead of Saturday because the
Catholic Church transferred the
solemnity from Saturday to Sunday can
they deny it if it stands in their
catechism no and can anybody else deny
it can they say no but Rome's changed
all right now let's get to the issue of
rest not the creator of the universe in
Genesis 21-3 but the Catholic church can
claim the honor of having granted man a
pause to his work every seven
days so that must tell you what why did
they want to change it ahuh because they
want to be the one that give you rest
yeah from your labor mhm but they don't
want to accept the righteousness of
Christ they've rejected it reason and
Common Sense demand the acceptance of
one or the other of these Alternatives
either protestantism and the keeping
holy of Saturday or catholicity and the
keeping holy of Sunday compromises
impossible you see why they were able to
sign a joint declaration is because they
compromis they compromised because they
had already compromised on the Saturday
Sunday issue and once you compromise on
one of the laws of the of God the others
will follow all right so when the
seventh day Baptists keep the
Sabbath then they cannot compromise on
the issue Sabbath Sunday when the
seventh day Adventists keep the Saturday
they're also not compromising they're
keeping the law of God and here the
Catholic Church says that compromises is
impossible you either Keep Saturday and
follow the Bible or you keep Sunday and
you follow them that's it so the day is
not the issue no it's the authority
behind it yes whose word are you
accepting who are you going to worship
and how are you going to
worship well the Lord's Day alliance
which is a Protestant organization puts
it frankly Sunday is a Mark of Christian
Unity you see that's but it's the mark
of the beast yeah and this is a big bone
of contention the Lord's day but you can
easily see that Sabbath the seventh day
Sabbath is the Lord's day yes so he's
lord of the
Sabbath it cannot change to Sunday being
the Lord's Day Isaiah says clearly the
Lord's holy day so the Catholic records
stated that Sunday is founded not on
script but on tradition and is
distinctly a Catholic
institution the New Testament makes no
explicit mention that the apostles
changed the day of worship but we know
it from tradition this is the new
revised Baltimore
catechism how be it says Jesus in vain
they do worship me teaching for
doctrines the Commandments of men for
laying aside the Commandments of God you
hold the traditions of men and the
washing of pots and cups and many such
other things ye do he could add here
keeping a different day than the one
that I ordained because of tradition
because of traditions you're worshiping
in vain is it an issue of worship
yeah right there's another statement the
first commandment of the church the
observance of Sunday and holy days
that's their most important
commandment in the first commandment of
the church the solemn observance of the
holy days is enjoined upon us there are
seven festivals of Our Lord five of our
Lady and three of the
Saints in the Catholic Christian
instructed it States has the Catholic
Church power to make an any alteration
in the Commandments of God and they
State instead of the seventh day and
other festivals appointed by the holy
law the church has prescribed this
Sunday and holy days is to be set apart
for God's worship and these we are now
obliged to keep in consequence of God's
Commandments instead of the ancient
Sabbath with what right their own right
their own right is that presumption yes
all right but Martin the deeper issue if
the Sabbath stands for
rest then it means you rest in the
completed works of Christ and you have
appropriated the righteousness of Christ
M do they reject the righteousness of
Christ and work for towards their own
righteousness ACC according to their
Works do they give remission of
punishment in purgatory which doesn't
exist in the Bible by appropriating that
Merit from the Saints and Jesus they say
and Mary and passing it on to others yes
so they concoct their their own
salvation it's a it's a total system of
worship it is a beastly if I may use a
pun system here's the apostolic letter
DS dominee of the Holy Father John Paul
II to the Bishops clergy and faithful of
the Catholic
church and he says when through the
century she the church has made laws
concerning
Sunday the CH church had in mind the
workers so in this matter my predecessor
Pope Leo the 13th in encyclical rum
novarum spoke of Sunday rest as a
worker's right which the state must
guarantee John Paul II who's now a saint
by the
way claimed that the state must
guarantee Sunday rest that's church and
state whose authority must the state
therefore acknowledge Rome Rome now
Martin if the state acknowledges the
authority of Rome do they thereby
axiomatically reject the authority of
God yes and they having said that Sunday
rest is the mark of their Authority and
they being the Beast of Revelation
chapter
13 does the state and anybody who
observes this command then receive the
mark of the beast unfortunately you
do okay the present Pope is he pushing
for Sunday yes on Sunday our
participation in the Eucharist has
special importance Sunday like The
Jewish Sabbath is meant to be a day
which heals our relationship with God
with ourselves and with others it also
proclaims man's Eternal rest in God does
it no I thought the seventh day
Sabbath determines that rest so if you
change the day you don't enter into that
rest and they don't believe in the rest
anyway no they've claimed everything for
themselves they must work in order to do
it in this way Christian spirituality
incorporates the value of relaxation and
festivity this is a total Distortion of
the
Gospel the right to disconnect and the
need for a European weekly common day of
rest this is the European Sunday allign
so it's not just America that does this
every nation Christian Nation will
follow and the others will receive it on
the hand because it'll be a banking
holiday and a restful day and they will
all go along with it and climate change
will play an important role Mother Earth
has to also rest everybody has to rest
but on the Beast day yeah so this is for
the common good Martin and the common
good must become Global the nation state
is no longer able to procure the common
good of its population alone the common
good has become Global and Nations
must associate for their own benefit can
anybody Escape no if you want to descent
you're going to be in trouble you're
going to be in
trouble so let's try and wrap this up
the mark of the beast is Sunday by her
own Proclamation yeah not by our
guessing the mark of the beast stands
for a Plan of Salvation which negates
the
atonement and denies the robe of
righteousness so it's a a rope that you
weave for yourself can you go to heaven
with that rope no no is it therefore
important that you don't accept the mark
of the beast it is the last great
warning okay and it's linked to a simple
thing called the
day so if I keep that day and refuse to
accept the day of the
papacy I don't only appropriate the day
to myself
I also accept the package that goes with
it resting in the completed works of
Salvation that Christ has wrought
through me on the cross I am saved by
the blood of the Lamb yeah yeah and any
good
works are works that he performs in me
that's
sanctification let's just wrap it up by
looking at the typology of
Deliverance the great Deliverance that
took place in type how does this affect
the
antitype and afterward Moses and Aaron
went in and told Pharaoh thus says the
Lord God of Israel let my people go that
they may hold a feast unto me in the
wilderness and Pharaoh said who is the
Lord that I should obey his voice to let
Israel go I know not the Lord neither
will I let Israel
go so here you have two Powers one that
know the Lord and one that doesn't know
the Lord or won't accept his ways
exactly will change his precepts okay
and the king of Egypt said unto them
wherefore do ye Moses and Aaron let the
people from their Works get ye unto your
burdens and Pharaoh said behold the
people of the land now are many and ye
Moses you make them rest the word is
Shabbat from their burdens Exodus 5:4
and5 what the Pharaoh is saying is Moses
you making the people keep the
Sabbath you will not keep the Sabbath we
will increase your burdens you will make
bricks and we will take away your straw
to make sure that you work on the
Sabbath day so he makes an anti- Sabbath
law yeah exactly now what was God's
answer to an anti- Sabbath law it was
the plagues mhm and the plagues were
blood frogs lice flyes cattle boils hail
Locust darkness and the
firstborn right now what blood boils
hail Darkness are also part of the
plagues that fall when the final seven
plagues fall is there a link between the
two yes so we've established a link so
here was a type A Deliverance which was
physical and we are talking about an
antitype a spiritual deliverance from
sin and coming back into harmony with
the will of God by accepting the
righteousness of Christ the symbol for
that is wrapped up in the Sabbath let's
have a
look Moses said you will keep the
Sabbath Pharaoh said you won't Psalms
105 verse 43 and 45 and he brought forth
his people with joy and his chosen with
gladness and he gave them the lands of
the Heathen and they inherited the labor
of the people that they might observe
his statutes and keep his laws praise ye
the Lord is coming back into harmony
with the will of God and the law of God
part of this plan yes it's part of your
Redemption of your going towards the
land of Canaan will it be the same at
the end yes all right and then there was
a test of obedience this is very
interesting
Exodus 16:4 then the Lord said to Moses
I will reain down bread from heaven for
you and the people ought to go out each
day and gather enough for that day in
this way I will test them that I may
prove them whether they will walk in my
law or
no so this law Martin did it exist
before sin yes because this was already
this was be written in the Bible also
before sin
correct Exodus 16:26 6 days You Shall
Gather it but on the seventh day which
is the Sabbath in it there shall be none
he was going to test them whether they
want to keep God's law yeah did he test
them specifically on the Sabbath issue
yes Martin if that was the type what
will be the antitype exactly the same
and it will be Universal okay here's
another
question uh there was food asso
apprciated it
lifestyle and they received Mana the
bread the
bread and they did not receive flesh
Foods were they happy with that
situation no they were murmuring they
were murmuring right so was a
lifestyle
associated with this process of
obedience yes about this whole
Redemption was it associated with a s
sabath keeping Nation yeah so did the
Sabbath keeping Nation have a health
component to The Obedience yes didn't
God say if you obey me then none of the
diseases of the Egyptians will be upon
you didn't he say that so can you
separate the medical missionary work the
health message from The Mark of the
Beast no it's like we mentioned the
right arm of this message that has to go
out so was there was a package deal and
the Sabbath was particularly chosen as
the test as to whether they will walk in
my law or
no and it'll be the same at the end
right the type cannot now be distorted
it will be the same in the anti okay so
let's just wrap this up Martin this
sabbath is it just about the day or is
it about the whole package of Salvation
the whole package it's about your
worship The Authority in your life all
of it all of it okay so it becomes
pivotal but it becomes a test was there
a test in the Garden of Eden yes did it
involve diet yes will there be a test at
the end and will it involve diet but
this is very fascinating the the Bible
is a very complete document God showed
us in type in written word what it will
be like in the end yes and we are here
we are here so we must learn from what
remember what has happened there okay
now has the world come to the point
where the issue of
diet has become very prominent in the
media as to what is healthy and what is
not healthy the issue of me eating has
that become very prominent very
prominent they even pulled it through to
this whole climate
change okay so people can make choices
right uh Exodus 16: 29 see for that the
Lord has given you the Sabbath therefore
he giveth you on the sixth day the bread
of two days abide ye every man in his
place let no man go out of his place on
the seventh day and it was so strict
that if you did it you got the death
penalty is there a wrath of God and a
death penalty associated with the final
decision as well yes okay was God so
concerned about the day or was it the
whole Plan of Salvation it was the whole
Plan of Salvation and your attitude
towards towards it so Martin how are you
saved whom do you acknowledge as your
savior and your redeemer is it a worldly
system of works space or is it the
biblical justification by faith alone
that is the question that we have here
so the final plagues will be poured out
and they are the seven bowls of God's
wroth revelation 16 verse1 and I heard a
great voice out of the temple saying to
the seven angels go your ways and pour
out the vials of the WTH of God upon the
earth and the first went and poured out
his V vile upon the Earth and they fell
a noisome and Grievous s upon the men
which had the mark of the beast and upon
them which worshiped His
Image in other words if you choose to
obey the powers that be contrary to the
will of God but in harmony with the will
of the first Beast
Catholicism then you are choosing to
worship the Beast and if you worship the
Beast you're actually worshiping the
dragon yeah Psalms 2:12 says kiss the
son lest he be angry and you perish from
the way when his wroth is kindled but a
little blessed are they that put their
trust in him so M the whole mark of the
beast issue is a choice between God's
way and man's way it is a choice between
the Babylonian I will do what I want do
what thou will W is the whole of the law
and I will put God aside or it is dying
to self and coming back into harmony
with God by allowing him to work in you
to change you and that is the whole
issue John 14:6 Jesus said unto him I am
the way the truth and the life no man
cometh unto the father but by
me it's a central statement in the Bible
it's either true or it's not it's
wrapped up in the mark of the
beast because the Beast says my way
that's it or the highway yeah and Jesus
says there's no other way come unto me
all ye that labor and are heavy laden
and I will give you rest so you either
get your rest from The Mark of the Beast
or you get your rest from God that's it
and how do you know which one you have
accepted by keeping the Sabbath so it's
a sign it's a sign it's a assigned to
show whose authority you are accepting
all right let us therefore come boldly
unto the throne of grace that we may
obtain mercy and find Grace to help in
times of need so the only way to
Salvation is through Christ and his
ways and may the Lord make it
clear to the people and we're not
arguing about a day but the day becomes
pivotal because it is a sign of of your
acceptance or rejection of the entire
package of the Plan of
Salvation do not accept the mark of the
beast do not go along with anything that
is contrary to the will of God to the
Commandments of God Jesus kept the
Commandments we have to keep the
Commandments Jesus kept the Sabbath we
have to keep the Sabbath not to be saved
but because we acknowledge that we are
saved let's pray thank you Heavenly
Father this is such a complex issue and
there's so much confusion around the
mark of the
beast please Lord make people understand
that the righteousness of Christ is the
heart of the third Angel's message this
is my prayer in jesus' name amen
[Music]
amen